[Music]
police in Florida arrested a possible
serial killer using genetic genealogy
technology and DNA collected from a
cigarette Robert Hayes was charged in
Palm Beach County with first-degree
murder for the death of one woman but
more charges are expected in Daytona
Beach police say the 37 year old is
believed to have killed at least four
more women over ten years
Manuel Bojorquez is following this story
Robert Hayes was denied bail Monday when
he appeared in court in Palm Beach
County we hadn't put this individual in
jail he would have done this again and
we would have had another innocent
victim out here according to police
Hayes was a college student at
bethune-cookman university in Daytona
Beach studying criminal justice in 2005
and 2006 when he is believed to have
shot and killed three women
laQuita Gunther Julie Greene and Awana
Patton but on Monday Hayes was charged
for a more recent murder in 2016 Rachel
Elizabeth Bay was found dead along a
road in Palm Beach County Florida State
Attorney RJ Larissa it's not just
working the streets anymore it's working
with DNA it's working with technology
according to an arrest affidavit it was
DNA recently found on a discarded
cigarette and genetic geneology
technology made popular with companies
like 23andme and ancestry.com that
linked Hayes to the Palm Beach County
murder and then to two of the Daytona
murders police say ballistic evidence
connected him to a third murder in
Daytona and he could be connected to a
fourth Daytona police say they continued
to build their case before charging
Hayes Volusia County Sheriff Michael
Chitwood said he spoke to one of the
victims families they are absolutely
estatic they didn't think they'd be
alive to see this day come the Palm
Beach County public defender's office
which represents Hayes has not yet
responded to our request for comment for
CBS this morning Manuel Bojorquez Miami